der verein ist mit den veranstaltern
wohl zu überdenken sei die begründung
des urteils des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes liegt sehr
nah an der einschätzung der
versammlungsbehörde in berlin
aber das hilft nichts wir müssen nach
vorn schauen
losgelöst von der frage von verboten
kommt es entscheidend darauf an dass bei
den demonstrationen keine unvertretbaren
infektionsrisiken entstehen
da habe ich mich schon vor dem
vergangenen wochenende dafür eingesetzt
dass das tragen einer guten rasen
bewegung bei größeren versammlungen
verpflichtend wird und nicht mehr nur
als auflage verfügt und angegriffen
werden kann
die gesundheitssenatorin und ich habe
morgen für den senat eine entsprechende
veränderung der infektionsschutz
verordnung vorbereitet wir werden morgen
dem senat vorschlagen dass zukünftig bei
demonstrationen verpflichtend zu machen
ob eine solche regelung die bewertung
der verbotsverfügung der letzten woche
durch das verwaltungsgericht oder das
oberverwaltungsgericht maßgeblich
geändert hätte wage ich allerdings zu
bezweifeln
aber dennoch ist diese rechtsänderung
ein wichtiges signal auch an die
veranstalter der versammlungen vom
wochenende
wir hatten am wochenende etwa 35.000 bis
38.000 genaue zahlen liegen im moment
noch nicht vor
teilnehmer bei solchen bei diesen
demonstrationen die es die teilnehmenden
waren kam aus einem sehr heterogen
spektrum
ich hab mir vor allem in öffentlichen
äußerungen auf die rechtsextremisten und
reichs bürger und rechten hooligans
aufmerksam gemacht davon waren mehrere
tausend in berlin aber auch sonst war
das spektrum sehr breit auch die
[Musik]
protestierenden aus dem bereich
querdenken
haben zu großen teilen nach meiner
auffassung nach dem was wir an bildern
vom wochenende gesehen haben durchaus
problematisches verhältnis zur
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
ich habe auch von grünen impfgegnern
gesprochen sollte ganz ausdrücklich an
der stelle sagen dass damit nicht die
grüne partei gemeint ist ich habe das
konservativ ökologische spektrum aus
baden württemberg genannt die grüne
partei ist dort an dieser stelle völlig
eindeutig gesagt gehöre nicht zu diesen
spektrum esoteriker und im laufe dieser
versammlung kam es auch zu heftigen
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzungen vor
allem im bereich vor der russischen
botschaft etwa 2000 reis bürger und
rechtsextremisten haben dort die polizei
mit flaschen und steinen beworfen allein
an dieser stelle kam es zu 200
festnahmen und verletzten polizisten und
polizisten
wir haben leider auch einen kurzen
moment gehabt der bilder geliefert hat
von den stufen des reichstags das sind
beschämende bilder
klar ist dass der deutsche bundestag
durch die polizei berlin geschützt wurde
und zu keinem zeitpunkt ungeschützt war
der regierende bürgermeister hat dazu
heute mit dem präsidenten des deutschen
bundestages mit herrn schäuble
telefoniert beide waren sich einig dass
der bundestag zu keinem zeitpunkt
ungeschützt war klar ist aber auch dass
die macht der bilder sorgt herr schäuble
hat er gestern abend in einem interview
das auch noch mal deutlich gemacht das
dass da einer entsprechenden abstimmung
zwischen polizei berlin und der
bundestagspolizei bedarf
damit das in zukunft ausgeschlossen
bleibt aber da hilft kein drumherumreden
ich bedauere zutiefst dass solche bilder
entstehen konnten
und ich denke dass das eben auch zeigt
dass das spektrum der menschen die dort
am wochenende unterwegs waren
ganz wesentlich nicht davon getragen
wird dass die einzelne entscheidungen
der bundesregierung oder der
landesregierung zu corona kritisieren
sondern dass es um grundsätzliche frage
das ist eine demonstration gegen die
demokratie gegen unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung war und dass
wir an dieser stelle eben auch deutlich
machen müssen
dieser festen überzeugung bin ich dass
wir deutlich machen müssen dass wir für
unsere demokratie einstehen dass wir
eine wehrhafte demokratie sind und die
dinge auch beim namen nennen das
vielleicht als einschätzung für den
samstag wir hatten dann am sonntag noch
eine fortsetzung von spontanen
demonstrationen die dann im laufe des
tages auch nach dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes von der
polizei beendet wurden
klar ist nichts ist so gut dass es nicht
besser gemacht werden kann gewähren uns
also für die zukunft vorzubereiten haben
polizei taktisch vorzubereiten haben
auch die frage des umgangs mit
versammlungsverbote und der frage
infektions das sind der durchsetzung des
infektionsschutz zu besprechen haben um
das auszuwerten gar keine frage
ich glaube dass wir auch bei zukünftigen
demonstrationen hier in der stadt so
lange jedenfalls wir im pandemie zeiten
leben nicht umhin kommen werden jeweils
den artikel 8 des grundgesetzes
versammlungsfreiheit mit dem artikel 2
des grundgesetzes schutz von leben und
gesundheit jeweils abwägen zu müssen und
betone noch mal ich glaube dass wir in
zeiten leben bei denen der artikel zwei
schutz von leben und gesundheit sehr
hoch gewertet werden